and then uh like when my phone went off
on an exam
which is uh not good just like normally
an auto fail yeah
yeah so like what happened was is that
uh i was like
supreme to enter shikari right at this
age and uh
so my my second name is c right yeah on
the exam so i was right at the front
always
yeah and uh i turned my phone off right
and i didn't realize
my phone could turn itself on to turn
the alarm on
what i did no phones could do this some
friends could do all the sentient [ __ ]
is that yeah
this is the back in the day when the
phones had the like the batteries you
could take out yeah
all right right yeah so my other friend
i remember distinctly before the exam
he's like i'm taking the battery out
dude just in case i'm like that's
[ __ ] dumb yeah
i'm just leaving mine in man yes and
that obviously
i was sitting down in my history exam my
head's like mumble in the back and i'm
like
[ __ ] idiot whose phone is that what a
[ __ ] loser i finished the exam
comfortably
i keep kept getting louder and i was
like whatever oh you know and then i go
to like to the back to get because you
put all your back you put all your bags
in the bag
yeah and i'm like where's my bag
what the [ __ ] my bag like i was like
[ __ ] was that my phone
no no it's not right i got [ __ ]
grilled by the headmaster who was like
trying to cheat trying to cheat they
were like you know
this alarm this and it was [ __ ]
entertaining
like in the like [ __ ] whatever room
it was while i was doing this two hour
exams right it was just in the like the
reception area
they were keeping it they're like you
know it kept going off and i'm like
alarms tend to do that yeah
out of every ringtone you could have
chosen you just because
that [ __ ] woke you up man i don't know
like i would never i like i've tried
putting like my favorite song as an
alarm
and then you realize after about
something you hate the song
yeah because i remember university i did
like exactly the same with like the
killers or
like sometimes muse and i'm just like
wow i hate the song now i
this is not why i picked the alarm too
it's because the the enter this entire
song at the time was like they're most
popular and it just started off with
you know this one yeah yeah yeah and the
server was like immediately screaming
and uh yeah so then i was just like i
remember i was [ __ ] like tearing up
i'm like no i'm not trying to cheat
it's just it's really like interesting
she's just an alarm bro
and they're like can you prove it and
i'm like it says nine o'clock man it's a
little alarm bell and everything because
they
treated it bear in mind right this
school is like 200 kids total
yeah yeah this is a high school 200 kid
this is like a very small school and
they have my bag on the table like at an
airport being like open it up
open
and then yeah they asked me what was it
and then can you prove it's an alarm i
show them it's alarm then like i'm
crying
and then they just let me go imagine if
they grilled you being like it's a [ __ ]
song
i think i stopped listening to end of
chicago because i think every time i got
like because bear in mind right as a 16
year old thinking that you're possibly
going to be like kicked out of like
exams yeah like traumatic as [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude my mom's gonna kill me i'm gonna be
destroyed for life but yeah luckily they
gave me a slap on a wrist although i'm
pretty sure they should have like
disqualified that exam result but they
i purposely chose a song that i knew i
was going to hate
because that just especially if it was
like an alarm to wake me up because yeah
you can't listen to an alarm of a song
that you hate for too long yeah right so
you can that's actually really clever it
further incites me to be like
i gotta turn this [ __ ] off immediately
so i chose [ __ ] yarn cat
no i like i did not i mean like i could
not listen to that for more than five
seconds right
like exactly i was like this perfect
alarm material because at the moment
like imagine just like eight a.m and
you're just having a nice
sleep and then just from downstairs you
just here
it's like oh [ __ ] i gotta sound like
that helped me get in the zone though
like when i'm gaming
like repetitive like
dude i could man i remember i got like
four hours in this [ __ ] brain man
this what's this [ __ ] bro
what's the dance till you're dead song
you know the one
uh i see your dad yeah the compilation
like in one gaming session i got like
six hours into the
the deku dance till you're dead dude to
be fair that song is sick
i have gone through like a few hours of
that song when you're gaming dude it's
like
you're in the [ __ ] zone and then you
check over you see deku headbang and
you're like nice
that's
it just it just probably gets you in the
zone nyanka on the other hand
is just the complete opposite of that
where it's just like this really
annoying noise that you just can't
pinpoint yeah yeah yeah
just like none cat is like audible
heroin right like
it just doesn't do anything but he just
makes you feel sluggish
does heroin not do anything for you what
do you say what are you taking
it's more just like the more you take
the more you're just like i can't
function it's
obviously coming from an analogy from
three people who have never taken heroin
before
it's like that office joke right where
it's like why do they always talk about
it's like crack they've never tried
crack
that's actually one of the few jokes i
love from the office